welcome to this video playing easel cool
the national master from the US and turn
one of those guys where I have a
terrible score let's I again try for
this image after i blundered this
terrible game against grandmaster crets
who also didn't know any theory and was
basically lost out of the opening Oh
interesting hmm this side don't I don't
know at all cool so do betray t44 c4
prickly here or what is the point
interesting hmm that's really
interesting
hmm do I need to pull her that if i play
a move like we need to you can go p 6
i'll be six bishop a six runs in two
nite f5 at some point maybe i should
cover it for the moment I don't really
want to keep the porn but I don't see a
good way at the moment to give it up
just better do that later that's an
interesting way how we played maybe it's
more precise to play castles us or
something I don't know this looks a bit
and convenient to set up ok gala what
I'm what i want what i will do is i will
play a 3 now right next move firmly to
to break up the c-4 pond and free my
bishop I need to get the pass going f3
takes yeah then maybe even G takes then
a 4f four it's a no this is not a
position for pedestrian play you just
need to hit the gas here just a fear
yeah the big prove the big question is
if I go f3 you see going to play Bishop
a six probably yes and how am I going to
keep c4 then I guess I don't and Knight
a5 is really just a paper tiger at the
moment f3 Bishop a six-night if I can go
nitey form so I'm Bishop c4 I could play
Bishop d3 but that's not really great
now but I have no way to color it to me
you should a two assaults on a possible
version a six fish of a two-night takes
d5 yeah that's that's not that's really
not what I wanted to do really really
wow you're not scared of c4 and you
should be too Wow because of that is not
scared
hmm maybe c4 was wrong yeah okay and
although everything instantly of course
now I didn't see it I just overlook the
most crazy check
Jim
that's not looking great really not what
the heck yeah the worst thing is it's
it's completely it's so easy to play
it's so easy to play you can even make
tons of mistakes and probably still wins
check I'm not saying that he's playing
badly I'm just saying that it's so easy
to do I mean so I really have I have no
way to defend it not sure about g5
though it's still good probably but
rookie to g2 why not
before I'd remove the king yeah
unfortunately it's still not good he
allowed something but not enough
he wants to switch over to a 4
maybe maybe allows lucky night x g5 shot
or something wouldn't be wouldn't be
deserved but who talks about justice
here
hmm oh really check don't I only have 20
seconds he's allowing really some stuff
here check time warning check
now I'm so done on time the shack and
play all this and still wins check oh
yes him he has many better moose but
check check no no I'm probably good but
they only have nine seconds check check
check no it's general check check this
is checkmate checkmate huh huh okay yeah
well if you rely too much on winning on
time and just play crab moves then you
still can lose I mean he could just just
win we've checked all kinds of stuff
check for example challenge one point
where it will change easy where where
was that at one point where so very easy
win check check check I hear it's a draw
already but where was that check check
yeah yeah I'm not sure I'm not sure to
be honest around around here he does not
need to do any of this grabbing the
cords and stuff sack but it's probably
winning I'm not saying it's not you can
I can use the comp check make it more
more clear okay yeah he has made eh form
it maybe it was that that I am today so
I mean adds this kind of unconscious
flesh that there is something check this
yeah okay I yes Jesus one mate cheers
check check here's the other check
checkmate yeah so there was a force made
it was a very interesting opening where
I really was in direct trauma maybe I
need to I need to do something else here
I don't know I mean I'm I'm playing it
wrong and this is of course possible
maybe I need to go all the way back
maybe this is better yeah hard to tell
of course very lucky at the end it's not
really a deserved to win but I have so
many undeserved lost a spin competitors
will win one thanks for watching